Imagine watching the most respected, generous pillar of your community suddenly abandon everything you believe in to follow a completely new disruptive ideology.
I mean, your first instinct would not be curiosity.
It would be panic.
Welcome.
We're with the master and the disciple Jafar ibn Mansur al-Yaman 's dialogue, and the moment the opposing community fields its greatest scholar to handle the new converts, Salih and his father.
He refused to condemn without hearing.
He refused to assume guidance without testing.
Both would be injustice.
So jumping into this deep dive, the predicament we are looking at is just endlessly fascinating because it's entirely driven by the crushing cost of visibility.
Yeah, completely.
You have this figure, al-Bakhtari, he's the father.
And he has a son, Solly, who is the convert that actually pulled his father into this new religious framework.
And it's crucial to note they didn't just quietly change their minds in the privacy of their own home.
No, not at all.
They are highly visible.
They are deeply respected figures in their region known for like their immense generosity and their growing knowledge.
And that visibility is exactly what forces the issue here because the community the father left behind didn't just vanish when his beliefs changed.
Yeah, these are people who relied on him.
Exactly.
They watched him give his
his wealth, they benefited from his patronage for years, and now they're watching him direct his loyalty and his resources somewhere entirely different.
So put yourself in their shoes for a second.
Think about how terrifying that is.
You are sitting there looking at the father and son and feeling this very specific agonizing pressure.
Oh, absolutely.
On the surface, yes, you're afraid of losing the financial and social favors of your old patron.
You have been avoiding them out of this weird mix of gratitude and resentment.
But underneath that social anxiety, the fear is much sharper.
I mean, if your old friend has actually found the truth, then you and your entire community are sitting in catastrophic error for not following him.
Yeah, you're living a lie.
You are.
They fear the fault of negligence.
They know that if guidance has arrived and they ignore it, they are accountable.
But on the flip side, if the converts have been led into delusion, the community fears they're guilty for not intervening.
Exactly, for not preventing that error.
are trapped between the dread of being left behind by the truth and the dread of being complicit in falsehood.
Either way, they are utterly exposed.
So feeling this paralyzing exposure, they do what any anxious collective does when it feels threatened.
They look for an out.
Yeah, they call in a champion to fix the problem for them so they do not have to deal with it directly.
They summon Abu Malik.
The visiting Yemeni scholar, famous in his community for piety, understanding, and the ability to defeat opponents in debate.
We really need to be precise about who this is.
He is considered the absolute apex of their intellectual and spiritual hierarchy.
They call him the glory of a yearn.
When they bring him in, they aren't bringing in.
a minor functionary to smooth things over, they are fielding the absolute best mind they possess.
And they hand him this perfectly constructed trap.
Yeah, they do.
They lay out their anxieties essentially asking him to validate their avoidance.
They want a shortcut out of their discomfort.
Because doing the hard work is terrifying.
So they offer him two very fast, very easy bypass routes.
Option one is to condemn the converts sight unseen.
Which is the aggressive route?
Yes.
If he does that, he validates the community's grievance.
He soothes their anxiety about being wrong and, you know, maybe even shames the patron into restoring his favors.
Okay.
And the second option.
The second option is the inverse.
Blindly validate the converts.
Declare them correctly guided based purely on their visible generosity.
So that would give the community permission to simply run after them.
Exactly.
They could maintain the patronage without having to examine the actual theology.
Neither of those options requires engaging with the new ideas at all.
Condemning from afar is safe because it protects your ego.
Validating blindly is safe because it protects your wallet.
But the scholar refuses both of them entirely.
Completely shuts it down.
He states that passing a verdict without investigation is fundamentally unjust.
And he roots this refusal directly in the Quran.
Specifically, he points to the chapter of the inner apartments, verse 6.
What does that verse lay out?
It lays down a strict instruction regarding the receipt of news.
If A transgressor brings news, the command is to investigate it thoroughly lest you harm a people in ignorance and then wake up in regret.
He anchors his entire method in this standard.
I don't buy that yet isn't go and find out just polite avoidance?
Well, it's a fair suspicion from the outside, but that misreads the mechanism of his refusal.
How so?
This isn't personal scrupulosity, nor is it diplomatic stalling.
What he's doing is applying A disciplined standing rule for receiving an accusation about a brother.
The command dictates the sequence.
Investigation first, verdict second.
Oh, I see.
By refusing to ride out either to attack or to embrace, he forces the community to step off the bypass route and onto the path of actual justice.
He makes them realize that their panic does not excuse them from the rules of evidence.
Okay, so he takes their anxiety and instead of soothing it with an easy answer, he turns the mirror directly back onto them.
He has to, because once he establishes that true justice demands an investigation, he realizes his own companions are entirely unequipped to conduct one.
Because of their panic.
Because of their mindset.
Their current mindset disqualifies them from recognizing the truth, even if it were standing right in front of them.
front of them.
So he issues a severe warning.
What does he tell them?
He tells them to beware the satisfaction of past communities.
He warns them against assuming they already possess the absolute limit of what can be known.
Okay, so he brings in a historical parallel.
Precisely.
He cites the account of the people of Joseph, glossed by the classical commentator Al-Tabari.
And what happened with them?
When Joseph died, the people assumed Allah would never raise a messenger after him.
They grew completely comfortable with the limit of what they had been given.
They assumed they had everything.
Yeah, they assumed their current knowledge encompassed everything possible.
And the scholar is diagnosing his own companions with this exact same spiritual disease.
They are a community entirely satisfied with what it already has.
Think about the psychology of that satisfaction for a second.
If you believe there's absolutely nothing new that can be added to your understanding,
You cannot even process a new teaching when it is handed to you.
No, you're insulated by your own comfort.
It is the classical error of a community that is so terrified of losing what they know that they refuse to see what might be added to it.
Isn't this just replacing one certainty with another Abu Malik's frame for his client's frame?
It looks like a masterful rhetorical maneuver, yes.
He strips away their comfortable assumptions and he is undeniably taking control of the framework.
But notice how he uses that control.
What does he do?
He does not narrow the field to force a specific conclusion.
He actually opens the field up in a way that makes bias impossible.
He presents them with the only three possible explanations for what has happened to these men.
He maps the territory.
Exactly.
He maps the entire territory of the problem fairly, showing them that their fears are largely illusions.
Okay, let's break down those 3 readings because they show exactly how to diffuse panic through logic.
The first reading he offers is that this change is simply a decorative addition.
The converts are still fundamentally on the old religion, but they have adopted a new tradition, some poetry or a local custom.
So if that's true, nothing fundamental is at stake.
Correct.
The panic is entirely unwarranted.
The community can relax.
But then he moves to the second reading, which is where the stakes get much higher.
The second reading is that this stranger actually brought them a real increase in knowledge, something genuinely true and useful.
And if this is the case.
If this is the case, he introduces a profound concept to his companions.
He uses the analogy of the lost camel of the believer.
Let's unpack exactly how that analogy works, because a lost camel in that environment is not just an inconvenience.
It is your survival, your livelihood.
It is deeply rooted in their tradition.
We find this in the collected aphorisms from the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him, stating that wisdom is the lost property of the believer who must take it wherever it is found.
And there is another layer to this.
Yes.
From the canonical hadith collection of Altermedia reporting the words of the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, this same principle is affirmed.
So think about the physical reality of that analogy.
If you lose something that valuable and you see it in the hands of a complete stranger, you do not reject it because of who was holding it.
No, you don't ask for the stranger's credentials.
You recognize the property as yours and you reclaim it.
That reframes the entire dynamic.
If the converts possess an increase in knowledge,
That knowledge is actually owed back to the believers.
It is their own lost property.
The converts are no longer a threat trying to destroy the community.
They are just holding something that belongs to the community.
You swallow your pride and go get your camel.
Exactly.
It turns the converts from a terrifying rival into a vital resource.
And then there's the third reading.
Yes, the final reading, that the converts are following true prophetic guidance.
they have connected to a clear, authentic source of divine truth.
If that is the case, the power dynamic flips completely.
The converts become the guides, and the community must follow.
But what makes these three readings structurally brilliant is the unified action they demand.
Under reading 1, reading 2, and reading 3,
The required action is identical.
You must go and meet them.
There is no version of this scenario where staying home, sitting in fear, and throwing judgments from a distance is the correct answer.
Avoidance is dismantled entirely, which brings us back to the core anchor of his method.
He refused to condemn without hearing.
He refused to assume guidance without testing both would be injustice.
Having committed the group to this unavoidable inquiry, he now has to prepare them for what they're actually going to see when they arrive at that door.
This is perhaps the most difficult phase of his preparation, because truth rarely arrives looking the way the comfortable majority expects it to look.
So he has to explain the inversion of signs.
Yes.
He tells his companions that falsehood and truth do not wear the costumes we assume they wear.
Falsehood wears the costume of conformity.
It manifests itself in hypocritical appearances and strict conformity to accepted opinions.
It looks easy.
It looks popular.
But truth wears the costume of trial.
It manifests itself through tests, afflictions, and the strict opposition of passions.
He illustrates this with a very specific contrast.
The analogy of the polished glass versus the jewel from fire.
Let's look at why human beings naturally gravitate toward the glass.
It is a profound way to understand human preference.
Falsehood is the glass that has been meticulously polished by the hands of the majority.
It is smoothed out, designed to be attractive, pleasing to the appetites and perfectly aligned with the opinions a person has been raised inside.
It demands nothing and comforts everything.
While truth is the jewel that only survives because it has come through the fire of testing, it appears harsh, demanding and utterly indifferent to popular conformity.
The tactile nature of that analogy is so revealing.
When you hold the polished glass, you don't get cut.
You don't lose your friends, you don't lose your social
social standing.
You don't have to change your habits.
The majority always gravitates toward it because it requires absolutely no internal friction to hold it.
Exactly.
That sounds like wordplay calling the majority's choice polished conformity rigs the verdict before the inquiry starts.
Well, it would be rigging the verdict if he told them to automatically choose the difficult path, but he does not say that.
What does he say?
He says that because the signs are inverted, the standard tools of judgment will fail you.
comfort as a guide.
To navigate this inversion, you need a different instrument altogether.
You need what the tradition calls the sound heart.
The sound heart.
This echoes throughout the foundational texts and it is notoriously difficult to actually practice.
Deeply difficult.
It is drawn directly from Abraham's prayer in the Quran, asking for the day when only a sound heart will be of any value.
It also mirrors the diagnosis found in the peak of eloquence.
which warns that following desires and innovative rulings is the beginning of all trouble.
How does he define the sound heart here?
With incredible clarity.
He says a sound heart is simply one that does not insist on denying what enters it until truth and falsehood fully reveal themselves.
It suspends judgment.
Yes.
But suspending ego is against every human survival instinct.
We want to categorize things immediately as safe or dangerous.
Completely.
The proud heart denies first and assesses later, but by then the choice is already made by
The sound heart allows the rival propositions to enter, lets them stand in the light, and refuses to kill the idea before it has fully demonstrated its nature.
It is the absolute suspension of ego in the face of evidence.
And to achieve that suspension of ego, he demands a specific posture from his companions before they even leave the house.
He tells them that true understanding requires A posture of profound need.
This is the core requirement of the whole investigation.
Humility must come before the truth, not as a reward after finding it.
You cannot go into an investigation expecting the truth to submit to your pre-existing brilliance.
So he gives them the analogy of the auditor who already knows he is in need.
Yes.
He is invoking the instruction from the disciple Al-Numan, collecting the sayings of the 6th Imam in the lineage.
The teaching is stark.
The seeker who comes already full is fed only what he brought.
The seeker who comes empty is fed what the master has.
If you walk up to the door full of your own assumptions,
full of your community's panic and full of your own presumed superiority, you will walk away with exactly that and nothing else.
You'll only eat the provisions you packed yourself.
You cannot taste what the other person is cooking.
I concede that point.
This posture of absolute emptiness is not just a moral accessory here.
It is the fundamental mechanical requirement for observation.
If you enter the audit full, you cannot be fed.
The absolute emptiness is the only way an audit actually works without bias.
You have to willingly empty yourself before you can verify what someone else has.
And when he explains this, the text records a shift.
The hearts of his companions soften.
They finally understand the gravity of the task.
They realize what's at stake.
Yeah, they ask permission to go to the converts.
but he refuses to send them alone.
He insists on going with them, and he demands that they go today, not in three days, not in two.
He eliminates the final refuge of the hesitant mind, which is delay.
The community was probably thinking, great, we understand the theory, let's go next week.
Because procrastination is the swamp of fools.
Delay is where resolve goes to rot.
If the inquiry is a matter of justice and if the posture of need has been established, waiting serves no purpose other than allowing the ego to rebuild its defenses.
So they act immediately.
They do.
The physical actions they take before departing are crucial.
They repent of their sins, they repay their debts, they purify themselves, and they set out that very same day.
They don't leave room for the comfort of the polished glass to lure them back.
They ensure they are carrying no unfulfilled worldly obligations that might distract them from the theological reality they are about to face.
They step directly into the fire of the test.
Marching out on a single unifying phrase.
There is no power except through Allah.
It is a stunning turnaround from a community that began the text hiding in fear and calculating their financial losses.
The transformation from paralyzed anxiety to immediate principled action is incredible.
They are writing out not to destroy an enemy, but to honestly weigh a profound disruption.
He refused to condemn without hearing.
He refused to assume guidance without testing both would be injustice.
As we look at the mechanics of this ancient inquiry, it is impossible not to feel the weight of it pressing against our own habits.
We live in a constant state of incoming information, surrounded by shifting allegiances, new arguments, and people changing their minds.
And our reflex so often is exactly that of the frightened community.
We sit at a safe distance.
We protect our networks.
We polish the glass of our own conformity because it is easy to hold.
But justice requires the friction of the audit.
It requires the empty cup.
Which piece of news about a friend, a teaching or a position have you been refusing to investigate this week
either because condemning from a distance is easier than hearing, or because assuming agreement is easier than testing, and what would it cost to write out today, not in three days.